Speaker 1: we have a really, really interesting
conversation to play from Meet the Press that
gets directly at this inconsistency when it
comes to the senators who won in November
of 2020, saying that Donald Trump actually
won in the election results can't be trusted.
I'm not going to put it up on the screen again
because I get I get flak every time I do it.
I sent a tweet out shortly after the election
saying something like, you know, all of these
Republicans saying that Biden stole it.
They were elected on the same ballots where
Speaker 2: it would say Senator or
Speaker 1: Congress.
And then on the same ballot president.
So how could it be that the Trump Biden results
are illegitimate, but their results are legitimate?
Wouldn't they have to question the legitimacy
of their own election?
Speaker 2: Of course, they're never,
Speaker 1: really ever held accountable for
that inconsistency.
Speaker 2: Until now,
Speaker 1: Senator Roger Marshall, a Republican
from Kansas, was on Meet the Press and interviewed
by Chuck Todd on Sunday.
And in this conversation,
Speaker 2: Chuck Todd asks him,
Speaker 1: Do you believe you were elected
fair and square?
Speaker 2: And he says, Yeah,
Speaker 3: yeah, I was.
Speaker 2: And then he's asked about whether
Joe
Speaker 1: Biden was really elected fair and
square, and he says, Well, I do have concerns
about election integrity,
Speaker 2: and he drops
Speaker 1: in a bunch
Speaker 2: of other coded language
Speaker 1: that these people are now regularly
using to avoid dealing with the truth, truth
and addressing these issues
Speaker 2: substantively.
So we're going to look
Speaker 1: at all of it.
This is close to three minutes.
It's a longer clip than we normally play,
but it's worth seeing the full kind of arc
of the conversation.
So let's watch it.
And then we're going to have a conversation
about it.
Speaker 3: You brought up Bob Dole at the
beginning.
We're going to have our own sort of tribute
to him later in the show.
But I'm curious of this.
Senator Bob Dole conceded the election in
1996.
The last president has not.
What could the former president learn from
Bob Dole?
Well, we'll listen, I think that this is an
issue of election integrity, and I think that's
what's really important to Americans across
the nation.
We we value the the ballot and the ballot
booth.
We want election integrity.
There's a lot of controversy out there, and
I'm focused right now on making making it
easier to vote and harder to cheat.
I think that's the focus right now.
Well, I want to actually.
Bob Dole, one of the last interviews he gave
was in July to USA Today.
He actually was asked about the former president,
and he said this.
He lost the election and I regret that he
did.
But they did.
He had Rudy Giuliani running all over the
country claiming fraud.
He never had one bit of fraud and all those
lawsuits he filed in statements he made.
I'm a Trumper.
I'm sort of trumped out, though.
Do you know you voted?
You stood with those that didn't want to certify
the election?
Do you regret that now, considering all the
crazy, cockamamie things that Mark Meadows
and others were doing?
Look, I'm always going to stand up for election
integrity.
I want to make sure that every state obeys
their own laws and obeys their own constitution,
especially in a time of crisis.
So that's what's at risk for me right now
is maintaining the integrity of that election.
And I want to do everything I can going forward
to make sure that those elections have even
more safety valves in it, that there's higher
levels of integrity.
Americans value the sanctity of that, that
ballot booth.
Do you believe you were elected fair and square
in 2020?
You know, absolutely, I do.
I think Kansas has some of the tightest election
laws in the land.
We went back and looked and looked at that
to make sure that it was a safe and fair election.
So proud of our secretary of state, so proud
of our county clerks and those people that
volunteer checking the IDs to make sure that
every person got one vote.
We're just really proud of our Kansas could
do what other states could look and see how
Kansas does it.
And do you believe that Joe Biden was elected
fair and square?
You know, Joe Biden was sworn into office,
I called him Mr. President since the day he
would.
I still remain concerned about election and
I still remain concerned about election integrity.
I think that that we need to go back and look
at what did the states obey their own laws?
Do they their own constitution?
Speaker 2: So there is a
Speaker 1: lot of kind of
Speaker 2: mush mouth nonsense
Speaker 1: in there.
I'm concerned about election integrity.
There is lots of controversy.
That's one of those things where, yeah, your
side created the
Speaker 2: controversy out of thin air
Speaker 1: and then points to the fact that
controversy exists to say, Well, we should
really slow down because if there is so much
controversy, maybe we can't trust those results.
Well, what's the reason for the controversy?
Speaker 2: The other kind of coded line that
uses there
Speaker 1: is we want to make sure that states
obey their own laws.
That is a
Speaker 2: garbage pond scum argument that
they have come up with.
And the way that that
Speaker 1: one works, and I know some of you
know it is, you hear this line all the time.
States changed their election rules without
going through the Legislature, and thus it
is illegal, unconstitutional.
Fill in the blank.
Speaker 2: This is not true.
Speaker 1: There are provisions that allow
the states that changed the make all of the
parameters, some of the parameters of the
election.
There are provisions that allow that to be
done without going through the legislative
process.
In some states, it was done related to COVID.
In others, it was not done related to COVID,
but it was still done.
And legally it is legal to do that.
They insist it's
Speaker 2: not, but it is.
Speaker 1: The other
Speaker 2: kind of linguistic
Speaker 1: trick that they use often
Speaker 2: is.
When he was
Speaker 1: asked, is Joe Biden, did Joe Biden
win fair and square?
Speaker 2: Marshall says Joe Biden
Speaker 1: is president and he was sworn in,
and Chuck Todd
Speaker 2: rightly points out that's not
Speaker 1: an answer to the question I asked.
We're not asking, do you recognize that Joe
Biden is the president today?
Speaker 2: Saying no to?
That is an extra
Speaker 1: level of wacky.
The question is whether Joe Biden came to
be the president today through an election
that he really won fair and square.
And so whenever they say Joe Biden was sworn
in and he is the
Speaker 2: president when they are asked,
did
Speaker 1: he win fair and square, they are
avoiding saying he won fair and square.
It's just a game that they play.
And at the end of the day, the game that they're
Speaker 2: playing is if I won, it's
Speaker 1: fair.
If you won, you cheated, even if I actually
cheated.
Speaker 2: No, if I won, it's fair.
Speaker 1: If you won, you cheated.
It is only hypocrisy if you believe that consistency
matters.
And as we talked about earlier in the show,
they don't care about even appearing to be
hypocrites.
Speaker 2: I don't know what I
Speaker 1: was looking at the other day, but
in the lead up to Trump winning
Speaker 2: in 2016, I don't know how many
of you
Speaker 1: remember this when there were good
jobs numbers under Barack Obama, good unemployment
numbers under Barack Obama.
Trump insisted that the numbers from the Bureau
of Labor Statistics and from the beat from
the Bureau of Labor Statistics and Department
of Labor were false.
You couldn't believe the numbers.
And within, I think it was like his maybe
his first, but certainly by his second or
third press briefing when Sean Spicer, Trump's
first press secretary,
Speaker 2: came out and said, We just
Speaker 1: got great jobs numbers and it was
like Trump's been president three days, it
couldn't possibly have anything to do with
Trump.
It's for the previous week before Trump was
even inaugurated, a reporter said.
Trump called these numbers fake before he
was president.
Are they no longer fake?
And Sean Spicer laughed through it, but he
said the numbers are now very, very real.
The president now trusts these numbers completely.
They don't even pretend not to be hypocrites.
And this goes back
Speaker 2: to my commentary from probably
eight
Speaker 1: nine months ago at this point where
they might realize that they are lying.
They might realize that they are hypocrites.
They might realize that they are holding themselves
to a different standard than they hold the
left.
But they don't care because they see this
as being in a moral holy war.
And if you're at war, much like if
Speaker 2: you're in a literal
Speaker 1: war, you might say we might have
to do some things we wouldn't do in normal
circumstances.
We're going to have to accept that some of
us are going to behave horribly because we're
at war and the end the means justify the ends.
It's the same thing here that they see whether
it's lies, hypocrisy, whatever they see it
as a justifiable means to an end.
They believe they are fighting for
Speaker 2: in a moral and
Speaker 1: principled way and when that's
the case.
How can you talk them into behaving like normal,
rational,
Speaker 2: honest, consistent
Speaker 1: people?
You can't.
And that's what's going on.